[Music]
what is the Cartesian product of sets
let's understand this using an example
of two sets we have two sets with us the
first set T represents a set of teachers
the second set C represents a set of
courses taught so we can represent the
two sets like this set T contains
elements TA and TB and set C contains
elements English Spanish and French now
we want to write all possible ways in
which every teacher teaches every
language we can understand this using an
arrow diagram set T is on the left and
set C is on the right teacher a can
teach English Spanish and French so we
draw three arrows from ta to English
Spanish and French teacher B also
teaches English Spanish and French
similarly we draw three arrows from TB
in short we use arrows to map every
element in set T to every element in set
C therefore an arrow is drawn from every
teacher to every course so we get ta
comma English ta comma Spanish ta comma
French TB comma English TB comma Spanish
and T become a French this list is
complete because we get all the possible
ways in which every teacher in set T
teaches every course in set C now let's
look closely at T a comma English it
implies that teacher a teaches English
so our first entry is teacher and the
second entry is the course teacher and
course are separated by a comma and
enclosed in round brackets let's use
lowercase T to represent a teacher and
lowercase C to represent a course so
every entry in our list is of the form
lowercase T comma lowercase C where he
belongs
the set of teachers T and C belongs to
the set of courses C now why do we use
round brackets this is because the order
in which we write within the round
brackets matters here's the explanation
remember we say teacher teaches course
the relation here is teachers what avi
writes the first entry s course and the
second entry as teacher is that correct
since the relation here is teachers it
would be incorrect to say that course
teaches teacher so we cannot write the
first entry S course and the second
entry as teacher from this we can
conclude that the order of elements
within the round brackets matters
therefore every combination of teacher
comma course is called an ordered pair
ordered pair implies that the order
matters it is represented using round
brackets this is the logic behind the
round brackets this complete set of
ordered pairs of teacher comma course is
nothing but the Cartesian products of
sets T and C Cartesian products is
written as T cross C T cross C is also a
set T cross C is a set with the
following elements written within curly
brackets this ordered pair is the first
element this pair is the second element
and so on notice that the ordered pairs
are enclosed in curly brackets and
separated by commas remember that curly
brackets are used to enclose elements in
a set here the order of elements does
not matter whereas the round brackets
are used to enclose elements where the
order matters
now we can also write the Cartesian
products of sets T and C using the set
builder notation we write it like this T
cross C is equal to curly bracket open
followed by T comma C in round brackets
such that team
Long's to set T and C belongs to set C
curly brackets close let's look at each
of our ordered pairs to see if this
condition is satisfied now for each
ordered pair of teacher comma course
teacher T belongs to set T with elements
TA and TB and course C belongs to set C
with elements English Spanish and French
each ordered pair in the set satisfies
the condition this video gives us a
basic understanding of the Cartesian
product in the next video we will learn
about the properties of Cartesian
product
[Music]